hey sally jesus christ how did you get  in here i made a copy of your keys it  doesn't matter uh you need to break up  with ryan because i still love you ryan  my fiance the man i'm marrying tomorrow  yeah and what get back together with you  you've spent the last three months  relentlessly stalking me trying to  sabotage ryan's career and doing  everything you can to break us up only  only because i know you won't actually  be happy with him how could you possibly  know that there was a scene earlier in  the movie that showed that he's actually  a terrible guy  i actually don't love my fiance at all i  don't remember that oh you weren't there  but the audience is totally rooting for  me now so you're saying that your  objectively creepy controlling and  manipulative behavior is fine because  the other guy is a jerk look i don't  make the rules  i think i love you